je passe ce soir chercher natsu au japon
et j'ai reçu ce matin c'est tout ce dont
j'ai besoin pour bien m'occuper de lui
donc on oublie la vidéo sur ça c'est
très bien hop là
le colis est énorme jamais reçu un colis
aussi gros voilà société un mensonge qui
contient uniquement des choses pour des
animaux qui contient aussi beaucoup de
l'espace vide voilà y'a plus rien d'un
excellent je sais pas si ce plan est
bien je pense qu'il est vraiment nul à
chier et là je réalise vraiment à ce
moment précis que je vais avoir un chien
dans très peu de temps
première éléments une serviette en
microfibre à quoi va t elle servir et
bien lorsque tu transportes prochain
dans un sac qui est mieux qu'il soit
bien ainsi qu'elle fait du bruit là donc
on en prend deux comme ça quand tu es en
train d'enlever une l'autre est
disponible excellent au saas et des
friandises pour y pense et on changerait
quelque chose de bien
c'est quoi ça déjà en c'est mignon c'est
une petite trousse de secours alors ah
ça c'est de la boue cela laisse la
première baisse de 20 j'ai pris une
laisse ou il n'y a pas de attendait
vraiment un youtube eur 4 j'ai pris le
laisse basique tu vois un mètre
cinquante elle peut faire pour le
balader basiquement et avec cette losc
est ce que j'ai un petit harnais j'ai
beaucoup public
trois jeunes seront bétail j'ai vraiment
pris le harnais pour les petits caniches
les chiba je pense que ça correspond à
cette taille là j'ai vraiment fait de la
merde remords j'aime bien voir mais rend
vite fait et voilà un merveilleux shirt
je peux désormais balader en laisse oh
non il n'aime pas le pauvre non au oui
j'aime pas du tout il est fâché ah oui
un portant un coup sans que je n'ai pris
un taille immense pour que les chats
puisse se poser avec lui et qu'ils se
fassent tous des bisous et conçoit une
belle famille bien soudée et très
heureuse mais il est petit mais après il
sera pris va grandir de ou donc voilà
petite corde
c'est un jouet finalement bon là et là
on a des crocs cannes voilà pour pour
chiots des croquettes de bonnes marques
attention acheter bien de la nourriture
de qualité pour vos animaux car c'est la
source principale de problèmes de santé
il faut le savoir tout ça pour vous dire
qu'on a maintenant tout ce qu'il nous
faut sauf le chien donc c'est un peu
plus important a tout de suite au japon
[Musique]
et bien bonjour comment allez vous moi
ça va extrêmement bien nous sommes
actuellement vendredi matin je suis
arrivée au japon hier soir et la
première chose que je vais faire c'est
aller voir natsu on attend ça depuis
maintenant trois semaines on va partir
maintenant on va le rejoindre et on va
tous y aller parce qu'on va et ému c'est
parti
nous nous approchons actuellement de
l'endroit où natsu se trouve j'ai le
coeur qui bat but je suis très émue
[Musique]
commencions à mon pote tu as grandi
on t'a dit
groupe h contre l'attaqué par demain mon
pote trois semaines de procès
d'ailleurs je crois qu'il m'a un peu je
pense que tu vas reconnu je sais pas
mais as-tu détruit mon pull ça marche
dont les amis natsu agrandie de malades
regardez ça regardez moi ce grand
bonhomme et m'a reconnu je suis trop
content il m'a fait une fête de malades
dès qu'un chien s'approche de moi ils
veulent bouffer parce qu'il est jaloux
je demande comment ça va être avec les
chats ait un vrai papa il ya pas la
barre j'aimerais ça j'ai compris je les
comprends moi il est trop heureux il a
vraiment grandi je pense qui fait deux
fois la taille de quand je l'avais vu la
dernière fois on va sortir on va faire
une balade mon chien rien ça regarde ça
comme il est heureux ça c'est pas un
chien heureux ça qui montrent le bide
nom laisse mais là c'est en fait tu vas
arrêter de tout démolir tu vas attendre
et à la maison pour tout démolir tu vas
me racheter d'adidas après vraiment ça
je te le dis oh il vous dit bonjour tu
es bien là dessus tout est déjà un très
bon youtuber laisse ma caméra laisse ma
caméra tu dois m'en acheter d'adidas et
une caméra déjà allez on va se balader
ses parties moment allons nous balader
dans ma ville préférée
[Musique]
bien fier petites bosses mon pote j'ai
peur ce qu'il se blesse sur un papa gaga
obama il écoute bien j'ai lu un peu des
techniques quand ils font chier anglaise
qu'il faut faire et donc je serai
derrière mais j'ai lu un à un en échange
vous ou non par le haut
et attention la première mère de deux
chiens j'avais toit de ma vie on y va
ce n'est que le début fait problème
c'est qu'à pas de poubelles à tokyo ont
été obligés de le mettre dans ton sac à
dos à toi c'était la première balade
avec natsu j'espère qu'elle vous aura
plu il y en aura d'autres je pense qu'à
un moment on ira à kamakura dans le
sable jeux 3d prochaine balade
voilà j'espère que cette manière vous a
plu je sais pas si j'ai re film
aujourd'hui j'ai profité un maximum avec
lui auquel cas je vous fais plein de
bisous je vous dis à très vite au revoir
[Musique]
et bien bonjour les amis il fait beau
nous sortons de deux jours de pluie
mathieu n'a pas pu sortir
et là il est complètement excités parce
qu'il va pouvoir aller au parc à chiens
du parc yoyogi un enclos avec des chiens
de sa taille ce point j'espère qu'il
aura des chiens parce qu on est lundi
après-midi ce père qui est déjà qui
travaille pas il va s'éclater gambader
s'amuser
[Musique]
c'est toujours un bon moment si tu vois
ton chien heureux comme jamais et je
découvre un peu la sensation ces gens à
sortir avec leurs chiens être content ce
qu'ils voient leur chien heureux je me
sens un peu pareil après j'avoue jusqu à
tout moment de faire un arrêt cardiaque
puisque je crois que tu as vu comme un
con il faut aller vers les gros et nasri
c'était un petit caca lobby femmes on
rend au japon sur décembre ce qui est à
prendre la grosse tête comme son maître
a pressé il a fait un terrier mon gars
il a gratté les 2 août
ici le rsa sont de mon chien il trouve
les trésors mon gars pour les amis c'est
la fin de la balade ça fait une heure et
demie deux heures à peu près qu'on est
là c'est bien dépensé j'ai acheté un sac
et une boutique en face du parc c'est un
sac à dos et je pars le balader avec moi
grâce à ça et après un pas qu'on me
mette dans la tension voyons voir
comment il le prend oh là là les amis je
suis le mec le plus gaga du monde
attention
[Musique]
on est bien on va imaginer mois sur le
foot comme sa direction mon bureau pour
tourner est-ce que même équipe un peu il
se dit [ __ ] je me balade mais sans
faire d'effort physique c'est bien ça et
aussi le début de l'obésité attention
natsu tu dis à demain
allez dis à demain oh
[Musique]
bonsoir chers amis on est sur une petite
mine pour qu on est sur une petite mine
parce qu'hier on s'en est prise d'une
mine
olala comment sur la boucherie
aujourd'hui hier soir c'était halloween
à tokyo je les fais ta chez williams
milieu de 1 milliard de japonais j'ai vu
des mecs arrivée dans des casses tuner
en mode tokyo drift est en fait il était
hyper simple tellement sympa qui nous
ont fait faire un tour à la palme c'est
que mon producteur parlait pas un mot
d'anglais donc quand je le film et il
savait pas trop comment réagir le pauvre
j'ai aussi croisé des gens qui étaient
chargés de ramasser les poubelles des
bois finalement quitté déguisé en mario
et luigi
aujourd'hui on est où on est à kamakura
ya pas mal de temples ici il ya aussi ce
que red bull à une statue de bouddha et
fait 13 228 tonnes c'est juste
incroyable
la plage est à seulement 300 mètres
d'ici donc on va clairement y aller
votre choix d'un café entre temps [ __ ]
je suis rentré très tard hier
d'halloween mais c'est incroyable bordel
c'est génial on arrive enfin pas
viennent pas car tu quittes averti des
tsunamis en cas de tremblement de terre
attention aux tsunamis qu'il a provoqués
ils te disent cargo mca pas d'alarmé il
peut y avoir un tsunami plus ou moins
gros qui arrive donc faut être attentif
et et remarqué s'il ya des choses
étranges temps c'est flippant alors
attention à temps je te retire ça a un
coût rires tu es libre alors j'ai une
frayeur nul de mettre nul tu peur qu'un
de ses énormes oiseaux le shop et
s'envole avec natsu ces faits les potes
sur la plage ça c'est beau ça
[Musique]
demain derniers jours au japon avant le
retour le but ça va être qui se
dépensent un max que dans l'avion ils
dorment le plus possible je suis anxieux
mais pas trop ce qu'il est très cool et
très calme je sais au moins que fera pas
chier les autres passagers du vol
comment va-t-il réagir face au chat de
la maison c'est la grosse question un
chemin
[Musique]
ça y est il est chez moi
bon je vais pas vous mentir j'ai pas
filmer l'arrivée dans l'appartement
parce que qu après douze heures de vol
j'étais un peu mort mais en tout cas
dans la course assez trop bien passé
natsuna pas hurler une fois il a été le
chien touchons petits seins arrivant à
l'appartement en fait les chats se sont
juste planqué j'interdis à nice où
l'accès à la chambre
donc les chats se réfugier dans après
ils ont pas l'air d'avoir peur plus que
ça en vrai mais pour l'acclimatation à
mettre plusieurs jours c'est normal est
ce que vous avez remarqué mme montpetit
qui donne au stylet 1 est lui coté
gymnaste a fait trois ans qu'il enfin
bon voilà ça fait bizarre de l'avoir à
la maison je réalise toujours pas je
suis un peu parano j'ai toujours
l'impression qu'ils s'ennuient ou qu'il
est triste parce qu'il pleut japon car
quand ray je pense qu'ils s'en fout mais
je ne sais pas j'ai trop peur pour lui
je n'aime tellement tu vraiment gaga de
ce chien c'est très très grave il
faudrait un numéro dette pour les gens
trop gaga de leurs animaux tu as de la
piste sur la pâte je sens et humide
c'est bien la piste alors ils pissent là
dessus à la maison quand même pas que tu
puisses par terre comme au ciel est bien
éduqué ok plus d'être évité à bientôt
dans une prochaine vidéo que vous m la
12 ème alors aimez vous vous même ce
pire outreau
pour
[Musique]